pushing beyond what you're comfortable
with just keep pushing and you got to
push your body pushing yourselves push
through push push further push through
push it through push yourself own way
hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about how you can push yourself
through fear and as always if you hear
something that really really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well
if you get to a place where it's easy as
an entrepreneur it's about to get really
really hard and so what you find is with
really good entrepreneurs they're
constantly making things difficult for
themselves and it's pushing I like to
say you push until it hurts or you sort
of you want to be always pushing beyond
what you're comfortable with and your
sweating just a little bit all the time
and and when that happens when you're
when you're constantly pushing beyond
what you think what you know is possible
you're always sweating a little bit and
you're always a little bit nervous but
that is the drug of being an
entrepreneur and so when you're pushing
like that and you're never really
relaxed then it always feels small and
so in many ways it feels to me the same
now as it did at the beginning it's
still a little nervous haha usually in
companies there's a notion of a
hierarchy a set of objectives a
quarterly plans or we had none of that
our theory was that the leadership in
particular the Bottoms Up leadership
really should be empowered by what we
were doing and we'd see how far they get
we didn't have an eighteen-month
strategy we just kept iterating so what
I learned from this is it fast iteration
is the key the most important thing to
do is every week a new product a new
idea just keep pushing you'd be amazed
how much progress you make in three
months or six months I've watched and
I've seen different athletes over the
years are not only Jamaicans Wichita
leads when they're training they were
they try to overdo it you got to work
with what the code says a lot
put in run hard hard hard hard and then
you can't finish it it's never like that
one thing I've learned over the years
for my coach that that's what is the
most important one that's when you
improve so if you run you got 1605 and
you're just tired you're dying you got
it even take one take a little bit more
time take one more minute and go because
that's when you started prove and that's
when the work pays off and I'll cause
you your legs are dead and you got to
push your body you got over comments
like you're moving past a barrier or
more moving step forward a lot of people
just want to stop because they're dead
tired but you gotta do that extra one
that's when it improve would actually
encourage all of you you know at some
point in your life you know you have to
work with people where you feel a bit
insecure that's essential because that
means you're working with people who are
better than you and we're pushing you
right and so I always encourage if you
if you actually feel very secure in what
you do you know that means you're doing
something comfortable and you're not
pushing yourself and so there are many
many times I've felt working with people
in a group am i doing enough these
people seem much better than me and I
think I think that's a inherent part of
learning you know I have a terrible fear
that I lay awake at night with that's
the fear of failure and the
embarrassment that comes with it and so
people like to have a lot of pride and
say you know I'm I'm not embarrassed or
not I think anybody that's an
entrepreneur deep down really deep down
in their soul has a fear of failure what
will people say what will people think
and it's hard it's a hard challenge and
so I try to ignore it as much as I can
but I I find it kind of haunting me and
so I push through because I really
believe that I have an obligation to
keep trying and trying
in trying and I've had plenty of failure
in my life what happened was when I
turned 35 in 2008/9 happened I became
much more comfortable with admitting my
vulnerability acknowledging my mistakes
saying when I was wrong showing my cards
and saying I was stupid
crumbs could be one of those situations
where I tried to outsmart something and
now I don't think it's gonna fail but I
have to be realistic
it could anything I do could fail better
than life more hair comes free nobody is
going to give anybody anything now you
get out of life you willing to put into
hard work sacrifice dedication all these
things breathe success now I can tell
you this because you know I was once one
of the people who were assumed to be
less likely to become successful I'm
from a very modest neighborhood I think
you know I did necessarily grow up with
a silver spoon in my mouth I have all
things that I wanted sometimes I think
in all things
me but it's important for you to know
your environment does not define you
unless you allow it to the position I
should hand right now the position
you're here right now does not dictate
your future unless you allow it to you
can look at your life as it is right now
you can look at it you can say well I'm
not well it's a isn't what my life will
need you can do one or two things you
could use it as an excuse to do nothing
but you could use it as motivation to
push yourself all the choice is yours I
need you guys understand and believe
that anything in life is possible
whatever it is you want to do is
absolutely possible I don't care I'm
going to trouble you've got it - up
until now I don't care how many things
you may have done wrong I don't care how
much you may not have in your life to
help you you can do it if you believe in
yourself enough to make it happen
if you put enough if you put enough
effort in energy and invest enough in
your future you can do anything in this
word if you want to do anything's
possible don't never let nobody tell you
what you can't do I started rapping when
I was nine years old nine years old and
I'm from Atlanta so every time when I
was record that wasn't no other rappers
in Atlanta and I heard every excuse why
I couldn't be around I heard every
excuse why I couldn't be famous
everything from you can't grab you too
skinny
you know everything from don't know that
it from the South maybe go placard
I heard all these things a whole bunch
of excuses a whole bunch of reasons why
I should not believe that I can make but
my belief my belief overcame that doubt
because I believe in myself and if I can
do it whatever it is that I have done
you what do you do when you when you
change how the world thinks of cinema
well what's next I mean do you keep
making the same kind of film or a few
person like Rosselini if you are you try
something experimental you push further
it's not just experimental for
experimental experiments sake but you
push the boundaries further see I'm a
seed I really am I see but a seed has to
be planted a seed got to have dirt put
on top of it if you take a seed and
throw it on the concrete and walk off
the Sun just burn it up but guess what
logically in my mind it doesn't make
sense that to grow something you should
dig a hole put it down in there and
cover it with dirt logically that don't
make no sense to me but odo see dirt is
necessary for growth and development
dirt builds character
Delp gives you the push-through factor
dirt makes you come with it when you
don't feel like coming with it no more
and you get dirt in a lot of different
ways all the other had dirt fold on you
and dirt ain't always what you want it's
somebody talking about you down on your
job it's somebody accusing you or
something that you didn't do if somebody
telling you you ain't gonna make it if
somebody shared information about you
that ain't true got everybody get dirt
put on them but see when you getting put
under that stress please know God as
always we're in Kurt Franklin song God
is always working so I smile because I
know he back there see that dirt builds
character in you when they talking about
you it teaches you to withstand it then
it gives you something to push through
so when you put the seed and you put the
dirt on it if you understand stress
stress really ain't just dirt stress see
they don't call it dirt when a planet
they call it soil because the soil has
nutrients in it what the nutrients when
people talking about your dog and you
lying on your back by stealing from you
talking at you they're actually putting
nutrients in you they're building
you got claritin now cuz now and now the
see if they put a camera on the ground
you'd have seen the seed sprout open and
start coming through the dirt because
the dirt is necessary so you improve
yourself you know if you don't really
want everything you see above ground
that blossoms and plants and grows and
that's beautiful it was underground one
time all them potatoes collard greens
they was underground one time then apple
trees they was underground one time so
they had to prove they sell so you want
to be successful well then you got to
prove yourself you got to push through
the dirt you got to come up through here
you got to come out then you sprout and
Dan Bishop saying then you become a
treat next thing you know you got fruit
all the things that that you were
honored for you think the characters
like Good Will Hunting wolves yeah Good
Will Hunting was here when the Academy
word for that is there any place that
you want to be I think that I am right
now it's a good play that's exactly
right yeah up to me about that just a
lot we share with no share Verna testify
brother yeah there's that feeling of
being you know doing like the standards
but combined with one hour photo
insomnia you know kind of pushing the
envelope in terms of what people
perceive I can do especially in playing
a character you know these darker you
know troubled and in many cases you know
nasty vicious and that helps to just you
know push it through because if you're
looking at now when you want you it's at
this age to say you're playing
characters now which is what I always
took was doing before but now it's a
given yeah you're heading towards Gabby
Todd oh god don't you see they can't
find any weapons good don't you know
what he's doing this can't you see he's
trying to defuse the economy he's
letting people go under hiring a man
from the dream because I ran the real
roads he was going on hoop well come on
Courtney let him go
but it's that idea of you know playing
these characters and doing this it's
been a great combination like a really
good year to just push the envelope and
I think that's always what I want to do
is to try different things and kind of
always change perception and change the
rhythm you could yeah break up it's me
as a rhythm it's basically saying okay
now we hit it in your bed
then you know hit a little harder and
then back off and then go berserk like
you know with the the stand up which is
just free form and then come back and
play something so controlled like I'm on
our photo those are all possible I mean
it I was trained at Juilliard you know I
you know went for three years and left
and then you know when did stand up but
the stand up was always just kind of a
great release and then still having that
ability to play you know both and having
that that range really helped for me
it's great and you mention the other
part having great friends and family
they just make life extraordinary and a
world to still go out and see and learn
about which is most important of all my
advice for the young adores would be you
know push yourself all away don't obsess
over what anybody else is doing if
you're given an opportunity and you're
lucky enough to have freedom to do what
you want to do on your career
why trap yourself why do something
that's not you thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love
to know which one was your favorite clip
what message did you take most from this
how are you going to bust through your
fear I love to hear from you please
leave your thoughts down in the comments
below thank you again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love guys I'll see you
soon